wildly a lot of video game news this
week huh
uh yeah why some stuff happens i don't
understand why why so much this week
i guess the game industry is trying to
stay relevant relative to the political
news cycle
they're like no don't stop looking away
from us maybe it seems like a very
counter-intuitive point in american
history to be trying to announce
anything
um but yeah i had a a friend
uh my friend steve spahn it's a great
initiative he
put together this list of a way to find
disabled creators
but he tweeted it on the day of the
storming of the capital
like from the capital steps and he was
like can you help me out
with this and i was like yes but i'm
going to say not today
because that will be useless they just
get totally buried it's
it's hectic but what do we get we got uh
the return of
lucas games yeah
which wow with the breaking of their
long-time you know collaborator partner
yeah
and branching off into ubisoft my
assumption there is that that was just
a contract that sunsetted it wasn't like
they fired anybody it was more like i
think it was
it was due to be up yeah like it was
just did they have an
exclusivity yeah yeah i didn't know that
either
they didn't make that many games like
when you look at it they did make mobile
games
um that you know we don't look at that
that much but it what is it battlefront
battlefront 2 and then fallen order
yeah but there were also a lot of games
that didn't come out that they were
making
that is true which i feel like if you're
disney
uh you're going to be like hmm we have
four games in this period of time
outside of mobile games again because
there are more than that yeah four they
they
canceled as many games as they released
right
what what about uh who who did um
uh does that force a force unleashed and
and force unleashed two it was that was
the as well
yeah that wasn't yeah that was like that
was before
this particular deal yeah those were
lucas arts
games yeah yeah now they're back it's
very exciting to me
i i don't know how i feel about it i saw
your
you tweet the um indiana jones i just
said discuss
yeah what is that boy those comments
were great what was the indiana jones
thing i missed this tweet
i just said disgusting people really
like the alarm i've set up didn't ring
my favorite one and i hope this person
is watching
because i want you to know it gave me a
tickle was like hopefully you don't
throw a fit
over this game being or people
criticizing this game
i was like hot day
oh my gosh i did you guys see that was
the tweet what was the tweet i miss you
okay so
troy literally just said touch gus but
he
uh retweeted that's right mike doesn't
follow me anymore i forgot about that
it was basically a cinematic trailer
announcing that machine games
are making uh an indiana jones game
directed by todd howard
um and yeah troy's tweet just says
discuss it doesn't say anything else
no positive or negative spin on it just
leave it here well i have this really
funny thing happened yesterday
um did you guys see the sort of
live-action
pokemon thing um i did not it's
it's really cool it's a really cool
video don't doubt that
um and i don't remember what they call
it you know like it's
it's like when people on the internet
make elaborate dominoes videos
i don't know if there's a name for those
like they okay go
like there's a lot of things falling
down ruben
kind of stuff goldberg is the thing
they're really cool know that
i didn't know that they had a name but
it's just clever that's true he knows a
lot um or informed education well
well there's a difference between sp
like rube goldberg is more than just
dominoes though that
that's when it's like that's like you
know more than just
yeah yeah exactly and it's a really cool
video
and i tweeted uh well i can't say i
expected this incredibly cool video to
be an announcement for a katy perry
collaboration
oh that's what it was at the end katy
perry goes electric
and it announced that it's some kind of
katy perry collaboration
katy perry fans are upset
like really really so some like
upset about my tweet but more upset at
anyone who replied to my tweet in any
negative
way so like i was reading through these
replies and be like oh my god
um someone are they using like weird
like abbreviations for her name that
don't make any sense
probably but like someone told one of my
followers that
they hope that they choke because they
said
okay the tweet for this person is not
gonna lie it's like sitting down to eat
a nice plate of homemade cookies and
finding out that katy perry baked them
because it's this whole video that's
good and then you're like it's a good
joke
what does it have to do with cape berry
and they said i hope you choke when you
eat your cookies
this is the katy perry stan account he's
like oh it's not even her first game
right she did the sims
she did do the same katy perry's been
around games for a while and i think she
likes pokemon it's not that it's like i
have any problem with it
uh but i you know i've heard about stan
twitter
but watching these people go through
every single
response and and just harassing people
as the guy who is always committed to
dispassionate analysis
the two things that pop to mind here is
first off
what is intrinsically upsetting about
discovering that your cookies
had been made by katy perry do we know
are there known facts
about katy perry nothing cookie and
that's i think the important distinction
is that nobody said it was upsetting
uh and but secondarily i'm also curious
about somebody
uh their offensive premise is sitting
down
alone i gather to eat a plate of cookies
yeah that's a that's a stretch i don't
know i feel like i feel
yeah i was going to say that's that's an
ambitious is that i don't think that's
supposed to be a meal
okay well ai take offense to that and b
among us has not
i don't think they they said anything of
that specific like do you also austin
are you in the camp of
you know because there's nothing
offensive about katy perry baked cookies
and that you would never eat a plate of
cookies alone anyway unless there's
something wrong with you that you
deserve to choke on said cookies
i'm clearly in the pro choking victim
blaming what's going on here
some people some people really like
being choked by the way that's another
thing
wow in though no that's a good point
he's not wrong that's true that's going
to be the animated text
some people like being choked yeah it
was just wild
none of the context leading into it just
let that cut absolutely everything prior
yeah
it'll be great no it was just wild to
see like to make such a harmless tweet
but
i guess i know katy perry
fans and i think it's beyonce and lady
gaga
and um ariana grande all have these just
fan bases that will threaten to murder
anyone
who maybe doesn't love the person
they're a fan of who dare be
and we thought videos were bad maybe he
would not
say like we've all got our community our
toxic community i think that's
i think there's something kind of i
don't know it's real it makes me feel
better that we're not necessarily the
worst
it's almost as if it's a human thing
it's all terrible it's all terrible
my my assumption with regard to accounts
like that
that they're 14 because the this in the
scale the size like some of these people
have like someone like katy perry has
more followers on instagram
than there are people who live in many
countries in the world
i think she might have the most on
twitter of anyone you know
there yeah i remember that true at one
point that was true years ago i remember
reading that it was like
you know it was like north of 100
million or something i mean it's like
so even if .01 of those people are these
sort of fringy lunatics it's still like
hundreds of thousands of people
absolutely and that's the thing that
like i feel like i learned a while ago
is
if you just if you have any kind of
large audience some percentage of them
are going to have
just oddities i don't know how to phrase
it that's
just some of it's going to be weird and
the katy perry is the third most
followed on
on twitter um or really aggressive
obama is number one and justin bieber is
number two
yeah i'm assuming this is yeah the list
yeah it's a funny thing is the funny
thing is all of our
not that i'm contributing a hell of a
lot to it but all of us combined could
the total number of people that that
represents in terms of like twitter
followers
could disappear from someone like katy
perry's and it wouldn't even look like a
rounding error
i was gonna say it wouldn't change an
integer it wouldn't be like like
nothing it's just really hard for me to
wrap my head around it
the thing that also strikes me about
that is i love interacting with people
on like this morning just a little bit
ago i i had found in the closet an old
drawing i made
as a kid i think it's strong bad with
the what was the the ghost looking guy
from he-man that floated
nope you want to know a couple people a
couple people figured it out finally
it's omega red from from the x-men uh
well from marvel generally speaking but
uh so you found a drawing and you
couldn't figure out what it was all
no i knew what it was i was curious if
anybody else could possibly
hey fam help me out there were a lot of
people that were like
what was weird
there were a lot of really good guesses
but um point being is like i enjoy going
on there
you know reading these comments chatting
with people and i realize
i mean you guys basically have this
problem already but then once you're
talking about 100 million people
it strikes me that it just becomes one
direction it is not
possible yeah
it becomes utterly unusable to
to read or interact because it's just
the the sheer number of like tens of
thousands
per second uh that would be going
through i mean i've seen um
jen selter who has i don't know millions
of followers on instagram
she did a screen recording of turning
her notifications on
just to see what they look like and it's
just like so
fast it like breaks your phone it's nuts
like it's so
so so fast i don't i mean the biggest
problem that i have is i
i can't really use my mentions page
because so much of it is people talking
to each other and i don't have context
it's not them tweeting at me it's
conversations between people that i've
been tagged in at some point
that have become a discussion under
something that i posted so i'm like i
can't
keep up with so how do you guys how do
you guys even i know that
it shows favoritism towards people that
you follow so i get
i get that but how do you ever even
use these these things because it just
it just seems like once the once you
cross a certain point it becomes just
noise i pretty often don't read any
responses to my own tweets
i just look at my timeline
mike's in my job i just look at my
timeline or the cleanup crew
i mean i read youtube comments because
they're manageable instagrams
i'll generally just see whatever's on
that main page but twitter i
i pretty often can't read replies to my
own tweets and that can be very funny
because sometimes
uh something i'll say will be completely
carried away in a way that i'm like
that's not what i meant at all
um wow and then there's this full
conversation about it it's been quote
tweeted and it's in a youtube video and
i'm like i didn't even that was a joke
wow and i don't realize for two days but
i just kind of have to let that happen
at this point
so yeah all nations have gone to war in
the background and wouldn't know it
wouldn't know yeah well my favorite
tweet
or my favorite response to the indiana
jones by the way was uh
xbox gets their own uncharted but it's
literally indiana jones
uh and i i was like that's i like that
it's fair
yeah is it is it meant to be an xbox
exclusive or is that just the
speculation that's not speculation well
yeah i was gonna say i have no idea if
that part was even accurate but just the
idea of
like you know take that sony it made me
laugh
yeah going in full reverse same as like
people uh
lost track of tomb raider being first a
while ago
right like these new teammates are just
uncharted yes i hope the indiana jones
game is basically
an open world game where you play as uh
uh what's what's the what's the guy's
name i'm blanking it's shameful i can't
remember his name
um his his sort of you know
like you know he speaks he speaks a
dozen languages and he'll just disappear
marcus marcus yes i hope it's an open
world game where you play marcus
that's my that's what i'm pulling for
man i could go into that whole thing
about how much they changed his
character between one and three
is just just to service the story you
didn't give it to marcus did you
go off i lost his own museum marcus
brody
he speaks a dozen languages you'll never
find him again he'll dissipate excuse me
does anyone happen to speak
that's the best was there is anybody
here speak english
we just need to do a complete recreation
of lessons
right here and now i love it was there
anything i knew you would call trailer
that really indicated
anything gameplay-wise i feel like it's
just look what we have
yeah and the funny thing to me is that
there is a whole generation of people
that were not even an idea
when the last movie came out
that are playing games when was that
that is true
crystal skull was like two thousand five
six
what was it something like that two
thousand five six ish range so i mean
that's 15. people are 15
are buying games when they're you know
when that movie came out
so i mean and even then a lot of people
already
and a lot of people are gonna be giving
you [ __ ] for even counting that as the
last movie
myself included i'll give myself [ __ ]
here's some [ __ ] troy oh i deserve that
there you go wow
dunk up myself first [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
but
i mean if you want to think about
between last crusade which
cannon is the last movie um
they are making another maybe that one
can be the new last i know
i i i that would be why isn't it if
they're making a new one
that's my feeling it's gonna be
every time you do a movie tie-in
it just immediately becomes derivative
and i've been
a bit a part of this to where you have
to serve
so many masters and but this thing is
like well you can't touch that because
we're doing that in this
but okay well then tell us this like we
can't tell you
i was like well let's try to be in step
yeah and a lot of times the movies
happen faster than the game production
so game production starts
way before and then so much of the
script or this i mean
there could be casting changes there
could be all sorts of stuff that's
happened
uh by the time the movie's out i know
that's been a
major problem with some of the star wars
games
where they'd try to put something in the
game and
lucas would be like no i guess disney
would be like no you can't do that and
they'd be like but why they'd be like
movie
and they'd be like but what specifically
is the issue we can't tell you
so it's just that they were kind of
maybe stepping on some theme that was in
the last jedi but weren't allowed to
know what the theme was or what it was
or why they couldn't use it they were
just told nope can't do it do something
else and
i think it's shifting i do think that's
shifting i think like
especially someone who's just been
through with with wick like there's
definitely
oh that's true you did this exactly yeah
there's like a generation of producers
coming up now who like
like good video games like i remember
very first meeting we had lionsgate was
like we want to make some we want to
make gold night now we definitely didn't
make golden eye with that game but like
they wanted to make a good game they
wanted to do something innovative well
you're not welcome back there they're
they're very disappointed in you
they're like yeah yeah yeah where's my
golden eye
i mean golden eye was deering the
like hiatus the bond hiatus
golden eye though right it was a tie
into gold mine did it come out in a did
they come out years later
i think it came out to tie in with them
let's find out but i thought it was
pretty concurrent
but it was kind of this magical kind of
for the longest time it was kind of the
only good movie tie-in right like it was
yeah
95 is when gold and i came out yeah that
was when you [ __ ] had a nine year old
yeah so it was a literal time they got
lucky basically like that or and also
just amazing designers on the team
but the um well in the legendary story
for those that don't know it
two years two years later by the way
where uh rare
was told specifically do not
include multiplayer and they did they
just they just
shipped it basically went completely
rogue and made it
nintendo didn't really realize what was
going on until it was past the point of
no return
uh and they they just fully were like
nah we believe in this and it's it's
like
it's hilarious very glad they did play
yeah i mean they
worked out yeah oh yeah for sure but
they were they you can pull [ __ ] like
that if it works
if it doesn't you're in trouble but if
you get away with it it's great yeah
yeah yeah imagine if we lived in a
universe where
everybody hated the multiplayer in
goldeneye so hard that it's all they
could talk about with that game like i
feel like it could have killed rare
right then and there uh whereas free
microsoft rare is still my favorite game
studio
they have made so many good games that
are still
fun to play because every play you can
still go back and play them but the fact
that like a perfect dark multiplayer
the idea that that couldn't have existed
at some point or at some point wouldn't
like they wouldn't have shipped it is
devastating to think about
i'm upset yeah and they're amazing that
they that they
are still around and still like relevant
that they're one of the
one of the few companies that have been
around for that amount of time
that still especially non-japanese
companies
that's still like very relevantly making
new games i feel i'm always
every time i they come up i just have
this moment of going damn they're very
impressive
yeah they've also done the flip back
into relevancy which is a tough one like
they were
like you know an amazing respected
studio then they kind of became the
avatar studio
for xbox for like the longest time and
then looped back into being relevant
again with a couple of great games so
it's kind of similar it's similar to um
frontier right frontier
great games in the past then did a lot
of licensed games kind of
went into that kind of um you know not
as popular or famous with gamers
and then comes back with elite with
planet coaster and kind of builds up
their reputation again it's uh
troy was that your attempted uh segway
into medium jesus christ
no did you see that i did i happen to be
i happen to look right at it
what happened choice haunted there's
my naughty dorks
my naughty dog skateboard my naughty dog
my daddy-daughter skateboard is that
your attempt to sound australian naughty
dog
my naughty dog skate deck back there
fell down don't understand why i did
did you see that there lana that is
pretty scary fell down
all by itself um i say uh i i promise
not to do this twice in a row but since
you did make a passing mention of star
wars
i do i do want to own up to
uh in the comments of last week's
when i said uh very confidently that the
battlefront 2 um dark storm
dark troopers start
what's in that [ __ ] mug of yours um
urine
really of a very intoxicated person not
mine that's what the
that's the weird thing not nor pams
which would have been which would have
been you know mike's having a moscow
mule let's just point that out that's
interesting
i can't lift mugs i'm rocking the
klingon mug yeah dude
you're going full rogue look at that
like you got the hair i guess the silver
sable you could like what would you be
going for right now
something really sad i can't lift a mug
that's why i don't have coffee
for the first time ever on this show are
you drinking
straw physically yes drinking out of
cups it's all really sad
how are you feeling it's pretty terrible
um but i'm so my knee hurts right now
but i'm no longer in trouble
pretty much jesus it was so bad when we
first unwrapped it i was like oh my god
um i no longer hurt when still
my knee does a little bit but my hands
are fine so
i feel like are you looking forward to
changing one of those people though
that's going to be like
the reins are coming uh because your
joints are all [ __ ] up and your knees
are going to be
my elbow is the weirdest one like still
my left elbow is
like i can only just yesterday i started
to be able to do that
on this hand but previously i couldn't
without queen's wave yes
uh but i couldn't do that for a while
it's really weird because the elbows
like you know don't look like there's
something wrong with them but they hurt
how do you how is is typing i can type
i can type but i have to type very
slowly no it's okay i can i can type
with like i move all my fingers now but
um you need to get one of those
uh like a stephen hawking you know eye
blink
uh measuring for typing hello my name is
alana up here thank you i
did try to play i did try to use uh
uh speech to text just once but it does
not understand my accent
no i don't have like an australian
translator the problem is that my
accent has a little bit of american in
it so it's just hyper confused
i like the idea that you type you say
like good day might and it goes
it's like hello sir
but otherwise yes uh you know it's it's
terrible but i'm getting better
it'll i'll be fine oh nothing special
that's trying to manage yeah that's
swollen i had a friend in high school
who was um
i can't remember if he was like playing
basketball maybe or so somehow he ended
up smacking his head direct like he
headbutted he and another kid
like full-on smacked each other in the
head and
he uh took took the injury like right
right here
and and it and he was fine i don't even
think he had a concussion although maybe
it was pretty bad but the funny thing
was that
he it started swelling as like high
impact
zones do and so his whole head swelled
and the crazy thing was it's like it
erased his facial features he just
became like a
dick tracy character tracy village 100
it was the most surreal thing where he
he came into school the next day and he
was just this perfect sphere with like
eyes drawn on
and a mouth and like nose holes and i
was like you should go home
what the [ __ ] getting rid of wrinkles
these days this is high school man this
is not a good place for you
you are nothing but a memory for us to
talk about on the podcast
later talking about on a podcast yeah my
knee went when i first saw it i wish i
had taken a photo because it was
absurd it looked like you had taken my
knee and added a baseball to the end of
it like it was just this knee and then
this
giant mountain of a thing my hands are a
little bit swollen but mostly just
disgusting
um trying to avoid infection and it's
it's mostly just disgusting
pretty much it's not it's not good like
this hand
i showed you guys a picture but it has
just like all this dead skin on it
that's just i'm not going to move it and
then this is the most metal podcast
everybody it's definitely healing with
dirt inside of it
that i couldn't why what do you mean it
will not come out
have you tried the spray stuff oh yeah
oh the devil
yes uh getting sprayed with peroxide
once a day no no
no don't do peroxide saline just like a
saline wash yeah that's that's what they
did when i
first called the ambulance this dirt is
quite stuck understood
so i think what's going to happen is
that it's just become part of you now
apparently
it's a borg as long as it's no longer
got any bacteria in it which i don't
think it does
reference very nice i'm just it
apparently it'll look like i have a
tattoo
when it heals over very good very good
um but back to the topic oh go on
all i wanted to say before and i'm glad
that you are sufficiently
i'm very grateful that you're
sufficiently un uh
injured to to get over the line at least
the bare minimum you are we can do the
podcast
so yeah in game industry terms you are a
minimum viable product for this product
alpha you're out yes yeah you're kind of
a yeah but all i was going to say is i
stan i just wanted to openly acknowledge
that i was
corrected on a handful of counts
apparently even i didn't even know about
this
in last jedi there is a very obscure
darth revan uh reference isn't like one
of the
props yeah so there's a there's a nice
of the old republic reference that like
so that and that obviously predates
mandalorian considerably i had no idea
about that and i'm a pretty huge
nicely old republic nerd i [ __ ] love
that game
and um but yeah anyway i just wanted to
say there were there was
fruitful uh education in the comments on
on the last day
i was wrong about why i like gyarados um
and i was like
it's fine i just know that i like the
stats when i play it so
whatever but this similarly like they
were like you're super wrong about that
and i was like that's fair
so you know favorite pokemon across the
board i was like yeah i screwed that up
my bad whatever
you know we make mistakes and we learn
from them but when austin does it it's
embarrassing because he claims that he
is the number one star wars fan so
yeah i mean i have a box of of the
action figures you know
it's really they don't just give that
away you have to you have to
you know you have to pay by sometimes
five dollars
so austin how would you feel if you got
to
work on one of these lucas star wars
games would that be like a thing that
you would love to do or is that
something that's like
your claim now or is it too close to
home or years ago
well it's actually not about the too
close to home so like i've gone through
phases of this question because
initially it was like just as a fanboy
it was like
that's the ultimate dream uh you know
like you just you don't think
you don't think about any practical
realities of a thing like that you just
think
you know i would be i'd be i'd be
assimilated into this magical
thing and become part of it and it's
like i i would be one of the red blood
cells that is
you would be the dirt in alana's house i
would be the dirt in alana's hand of the
of the star wars like i would i would be
of equal value relative to the whole ip
but still inarguably a part of it
uh no so it's like but then i remember
when um when ea started looking for a
composer on one of those games
they reached out to my agency just in a
broad way to say are there any of your
clients that we should be looking at
they ended up of course hiring gordy
habb
uh who did famously um i mean gordy has
tools in schools
i think gordy has his work on both
battlefront games and on fallen order
he's become the de facto
star wars composer he um i actually find
his music
despite the fact that it is overtly like
you must
sort of the way they describe it is
write the john williams b
sides like it must sound as if john
williams wrote this but we've just
somehow never heard these cues
and in that way i actually find that he
has out williams williams
he's out williams williams because if
you listen to his
star wars cues compared with the sequel
scores i find gordy's
more interesting i actually think he's
he's writing star wars more
interestingly than john williams at this
point to my taste
now the the that changes once you go to
the you know like empire strikes back
and
you know but the recent ones where it
feels like john williams has kind of
said all he
has to say um and it's very very good
work
it's very i'm not saying that it's bad
work by any stretch but i just feel like
he's
he's he's he's you know at some point
you cross
a thresh of course gordy himself is
written i think he said the other day
he tabulated he's written 35 hours of
star wars music at this point
uh because he also worked on you know
the old republic and connect star wars
and he's been doing it for a while
um but um did he write the solo song
he did not go but himself ironically the
solo song was the duet yeah
i've seen him uh i've seen him publicly
say he feels bad for that
guy because that guy came and did a job
exactly as suspect and he just
took a mountain of [ __ ] look it's
perfect it's just terrible
at the same time exactly so the longest
perfect execution of that idea yes
when they were looking for somebody i
remember when it was clear that they
were expressly looking for
somebody who could kind of um do
john williams's aesthetic so perfectly
to almost be
dif like indifferentiable from john
williams i i didn't even
submit a reel because i thought i've
actually reached a point in my career
where that's not interesting to me
now to gordy's credit gordy has managed
to parlay that into
amazing things initially when he got the
job i thought i don't envy that that
that
because he basically is having to be
someone he's not
like gordy is his own composer and very
capable if you listen to his score to
halo wars 2
you can hear him doing gordy and not
john williams and you're like oh there's
a real composer there
and so and and even on fallen order i i
feel like i could hear that i could hear
him
channeling williams he and stephen
barton who i really liked this um
it's very good i mean and they and they
went all in i mean that's
all done of the same production quality
as the movies like all abbey road london
symphony
it's as it's as extravagant as as is
possible
point being um i initially
thought no i i i'm even if it's
narrows my opportunities i think i'm
happier being austin than
than the quote john williams
uh because it i don't want to even try
that
um but i i have i've modified my opinion
because
i also underestimated that star wars
would eventually
realize it has to grow and expand and
between what john powell did on
solo which i think is despite how messy
that movie is the score
is unbelievable and then of course as we
spoke at length last time what ludwig
has done
on mandalorian star wars has finally
reached a point where it seems like it's
it's actually excited to kind of branch
out
and it has before all credit where it's
due jesse harlan what was the game
republic commando
uh jesse has definitely you know in many
many years ago he was
the staff composer at lucasarts before
they folded
he um he he was pushing that boundary
uh but those were you know those didn't
quite take off in the way that
mandalorian obviously
i mean mandalore is thoroughly
mainstream and and despite its
iffyness so was solo so i finally feel
like now if something like that came
along
i would absolutely jump at the jump at
the uh
chance because i feel like
they're not just looking for give us
basically john williams just rehashed
and that's very exciting to me yeah i
can understand why you would find that
extremely creatively limiting that's
literally what they're doing it's like
just sound like this guy
yeah like not just this guy like
arguably the greatest composer of all
time
you know like the and the most probably
the most heard
most listened to compo is one of the few
composers that has an audience of
billions
that is true you're dodging the uncanny
valley a bit aren't you there as well
like people have such an expert it's a
good way to put it soundtrack
yeah yeah yeah exactly jazz pianist
that's what's so funny he he he is a
remarkably excellent jazz pianist that
is also true
yeah i remember there was you may be
correct your you could probably correct
me on this but i remember him
saying that um
the score for uh catch me if you can he
felt was the first
score where he was like returning to his
runes because he was he was henry
mancini's
pianist is that right and he was also
the go-to
of if we can't afford hank go hire
johnny like a lot of his early pre-star
wars scores were
cheesy romantic comedies where they they
wanted to be making breakfast at
tiffany's and hiring henry mancini
but they couldn't afford either of those
things so they hired you know it's like
how to marry a millionaire uh or or you
know
uh sorry a guide for the married man
with walter matthau with
music by young johnny williams uh you
know that
clearly they wanted the mancini vibe
so yeah william's returning to that form
interestingly though what would you
guess there's one score that williams
singles out as what he says
is this most him like when he talks
about star wars
he speaks as a craftsman who's like look
i put on that hat i do the job for the
little kids movie
for them to enjoy on a popcorn saturday
afternoon but
the real me is ex really
yeah it's he's even he feels that way
what did you say mike
i said paul patrol i reckon it was paw
patrol
i would guess this is probably just a
cheesy one i would guess either
uh close encounters or e.t you nailed it
it's close encounters
boom [ __ ] [ __ ] right out of the gate
are you serious yeah yep it's funny
because that score
is other than the fact that everybody
everybody knows that
everybody knows that but that's actually
the only that's the wrong last note
i know get over it
[Laughter]
troy is is killing it he's he's got two
in the room he drank
he drank both his and alana's coffee
yeah so he's just
always oh yeah no close encounters is
that score is overwhelmingly like
borderline 12-tone music very dissonant
very non-melodic no
no memorable tunes really until the very
last q in the very last scene of the
movie
it's like atmospheric orchestra you know
slithering and it's funny to me that
williams goes yep that's the real john
williams right there basically a
mid 20th century modernist composer with
no interest in melody and no interest in
anything but kind of
texture and form um which is funny
because he's just like his brand is and
he's so funny
as the most memorable melody guy of all
time exactly yeah
it's not just star wars i mean it's like
indiana jones and harry potter and
jurassic park and schindler's list the
number of melodies he's written that are
part of our
collective cultural conscience is
so massive so out so far beyond any
other composer
and yet in his mind it's like well you
know you just you sit down and you
fiddle with the notes until they're
right and then you send it off to the
director and you move on with your life
but
if he looks into all of it he's written
a lot of you know modern classical music
that's him just like he wrote a cello
concerto for yo yo ma
very very there's no there's no melodic
content like his movies in these pieces
at all it's
so fascinating fun fact did you know
that there's a cameo so close encounters
are the third kind is a system
that was developed by an astronomer um
alan heineck and
they have him he was the guy that was a
part of like project paperclip
um that was the government's response to
going and investigating all of these ufo
conspiracy theories
and he was in charge of debunking that
and they do a show right now on
on history or whatever um about it the
guy
who played littlefinger i can't remember
his name right now irish actor
um i know the from game of thrones to me
for game of thrones
uh plays heinek um but i didn't realize
there's an episode of that show a
project paper clip where uh he's on set
of close encounters and i was like
what is like they actually had the that
uh
professor heineck was there on set for
close encounters because spielberg was
like this guy deserves to be here
and so he's like an extra the actual guy
who created that system is on set
i love uh little things like that my one
neil degrasse tyson told a story of
at the premiere of contact uh he was um
invited and there's a scene in that
where jody foster and matthew
mcconaughey first
meet and they're standing at the now
deceased arecibo
radio observatory uh horrible uh story
there but um
there's a scene where they're sitting
there kind of having their little random
you know romantic getting to know each
other scene and um
she says you know there's so many
billions of
of uh stars there's so many billions of
galaxies and if even just one in a
million of those
galaxies had stars uh of which one in a
million
had planets of which one in a million
had
life on them there'd be life everywhere
in the universe well that's a
that's a reference to what's called the
drake equation by
by francis drake oh i thought it was the
the artist drake
yes yes the yes exactly it was some of
his earlier work before he
shifted over in hip-hop um yeah so they
they
they said um the the drake equation
except she has it wildly wrong it's not
one within a million within a million
within a million she's off by an order
of magnitude it's
it was if one in a thousand and then one
in a thousand and the one in a thousand
you should tweet her about it well the
funny thing is that she cares about it
neil degrasse tyson is at the premiere
and so is frank drake
and he's sitting there losing his [ __ ]
the whole time going
they're getting your equation wrong
they're getting your equation and he
comes up to him after the premiere and
apparently was like
didn't that drive you crazy and he was
like neil it's a movie
and just put him in his place i feel
like you could say that to most things
that neil degrasse tyson
gets did i tell you about my interaction
with him at new york comic con
no this is right after
uh gravity had come out well that was
his big viral
tweet yeah so we're in the they are
they are about to do the panel for
cosmos
and he's there with sagan's wife and i
just like i i
i just want to shake your hand you're
like what your
husband contributed to science what he
contributed to me and my
search for curiosity and and and his
fascination
one of my favorite one of the best
humans that's everything yeah um
and so tyson's sitting there and he's
eating hot dogs
and um how many people once at the same
time
i mean that the guy i'm sure was doing
press
and i said and so i have this great
interaction and i was like
i have a question man and he goes sure
and i was like did you even like the
movie he was like here we go
he was like look he's like obviously if
they're gonna you know create a movie
um that's that's about my specific field
i'm gonna have to comment like
i mean if they if they you know did a
movie about
you know your profession what would you
do you mean every movie
it's always actors i was like people
comment on it all the time
i was like but that doesn't mean that
you can't i was like it had nothing to
do with space
i was like here's this beautiful poem
about a woman
struggling with the death of her child
and she feels that she's adrift
and i was like there's there's nothing
but metaphor and allegory the entire
time has nothing to do with space
it's like she's not even in space man
this is a whole metaphor
i get why he commented on it yeah i
understand
yeah same i think i think approaching it
as a
you know teachable moment while
acknowledging that it's still
fundamentally not about those things i
think his
i think what makes him take notice is
when a film
looks like they're going out of their
way to be realistic and then they mess
up some fundamentals
there's a difference between if you are
you know
like the matrix and you're just you're
everything about your starting premise
is like we're not even
there's nothing about this that is
attempting to be grounded in realism
that's why
looper was great like looper if you
watch the joseph gordon levin and bruce
willis
um right they just go time travel
they're like time travel we go in the
thing we come at the thing it's done
it's like just time travel but i don't
think that that movie set out to be like
here is what it's like to travel in
space the movie squarely states
its thesis george clooney asks
what are you thinking about like what
what do you think about right now she
talks about how
the sound of the radio comforts her
because that's what she would do
and she's clearly in she's clearly
grieving the loss of her daughter
and this is all just like a dream all of
it so she's supposed to read that it's
literally like uh
like a dream sequence like you don't re
you read it as
none of it's real she's not an astronaut
she's not in space
huh i i think alex alejandra corado
whatever was doing a beautiful poem in
the form of a narrative theatrical piece
about a mother struggling with the death
of her daughter
and even so like when she comes back
down she's
barefoot and she's it's the first time
she's on firm ground
and she stands up on her own two feet
they don't pull her out
she stands up on her own it's like all
of this is is is
poetic yeah but george existed
she could still be an astronaut but it
doesn't
it there's not a necessitation that it
must be accurate
if you if you are stating something that
this is like interstellar to me
was more like hey we're not talking
about like we're gonna deal with some
themes and stuff
but this is what would it look like if
we traveled to a different solution yeah
interstellar was also
a kip thorn paper that was optioned
like that was that was the basis of that
script was literally optioning the
rights to a physics paper
then do that neil degrassi was crazy as
well right with the render tech they had
to build they end up building
the coolest black hole yeah well go on
you tell it usually you'll talk about
well
i mean i don't i don't remember the
specifics too deeply but that they
basically because they were able to
apply hollywood blockbuster scale
resources
at creating a simulation that they were
actually able to write a re
one or several research papers about
black holes based on what was learned
from those simulations just purely to
make the visual effect in the movie yeah
it's crazy that's what i got to go on i
was on a panel with the the
the head of the vfx studio that did that
and it was just fascinating hearing him
talk like
the crazy kind of yeah the the fact that
yeah it moved on the science as well
like the existence of that movie has
improved our understanding of black
holes that's incredible
bringing it back to star wars i didn't
realize what tie fighters stood for
really for no for like the longest time
that was like a few years ago because
they look like bow ties yes
twin ion engine twin ion engine twin ion
engine yeah okay
that's what you know the ironic thing
about that feels like something that
someone came up with like
20 years later for a for a back of a
comic book
i was once on a plane next to a guy who
worked for jpl
and he said i said what do you do and he
goes i'm actually working on ion engine
tech and i was like i hope you weren't
planning on reading or something because
the next two hours ago
and i just i just kind of want to eat my
food and yeah he's just going to listen
too bad he kind of he was banking on the
idea of saying like i'm a jpl
scientist would make someone go like
yoink good night
and uh but yeah do you do that so so i'd
say that's my question to the group like
i
actively will will make my job sound
less interesting to avoid a conversation
if i'm tired like i will say
if i'm if i'm like on a plane and like
someone's
trying out conversation i will always
say i'm a programmer like and they
immediately just will leave me i don't
tell people that i work in games no
matter what because
if i do it is a conversational shift
it becomes completely inorganic there's
never a oh cool
what's that like it's you work in games
do you like video games how long have
you played video games for what kind of
games it becomes like very
terrible story yeah it's no it's never a
good time
never so i usually say i'm a journalist
which i guess i
like it was but i still say that it's a
journalist
and then i say tech because they get
bored
what kind of journalist tech i have said
before i'm a musician exactly
him uh in in the spirit of trying to
but but i have to i have a i actually
have a very hard out a few minutes so
i'm going to leave you guys early um
i tell people that i i just got out of
prison this is my first flight
and you were in prison for hijacking
something i'm super
nervous i don't know if i'm going to
want to strike again
who knows that's true you should get a
bunch of like rub on tattoos for
put them on your face you know for every
flight just to just to kind of keep
you know i start rocking back and forth
but i'm feeling much better now
i'm doing much better now um austin
before we lose you i was gonna ask if
you have any uh
closing thoughts on the lucas games
thing
bring it on bring it on i i
my closing thought was going to be about
ion engines because the thing i learned
from my jpl my jpl friend that day
taught me that the thing that's
interesting about ion engines is that
they're a very efficient way to go long
distance in space
but the the problem the reason why it's
hilariously
doesn't make sense at least with my
understanding for like
a dog fighting fighter craft is because
they're
very very slow acceleration that's their
whole thing
they're very low energy expenses like a
cumulative it
yeah it's it's like it's all about if
you if you want to be going
you know like a million miles in a
straight
line it's a pretty efficient way to
travel but you also have to start
slowing down way in advance as well like
they're they're not
they're the opposite of what a tie
fighter is theoretically supposed to be
yeah exactly yeah yeah very highly
maneuverable blah blah blah anyway i'm
excited you know
lucas obviously lucasarts is was my
my childhood that's why i lost you
specifically like i know that you love
those games
yeah and i like that your answer is let
me tell you about ion engines
well probably because i learned that
from lucasarts games but
uh i no it's true i'm stoked i mean i
i to me it's like i feel the same way as
when disney bought
lucasfilm and it was like look they're
going to start producing
massive piles of content a lot of it's
probably going to be
mediocre but if every now and again
there's a real diamond that comes out of
that to me that's exciting because i
i prefer that over the once every 20
years there's this cultural moment that
puts
so much pressure that if you get it
wrong now
you know george lucas gets death threats
it's like no i just didn't like i just
didn't like the
the mandalorian but i like the the bad
batch or i like the ashoka show or i
like it i do like this landscape of
picking and choosing which of the star
wars things you want to buy into
yeah and that's way more healthy for me
and it also emboldens people to take
bigger risks because it's now
the future of star wars doesn't depend
on your thing now
yeah yeah you're not holding it all on
your shoulders yeah that's exciting
that's why
i likened it to uh uh james bond where i
said there's there's a kind of a
continuous trickle and it also
periodically just reboots like
there's a new bond the none of the
characters carry over nothing matters
anymore and i was like if star wars kind
of got to that they never will
come in too what is it oh yeah right
yeah i can't wait i can't wait hitman's
next week right
yeah i'm pretty excited about that i'm
really bad at those games and i really
enjoy them i haven't played a hitman
game in years
it's so fun oh you have to check in on
whether right yeah before
before the none one like i did you know
it's like
yeah oh yeah okay
you need to get do you need to jump back
in now those games are incredible yeah
all right um austin i think we have to
let you go
yeah i have to let me go too okay we
should just
rap then i guess i am in physical pain
so
but before you do you should probably
introduce us yes hi everyone welcome to
playlist listen
sorry about this short episode uh i'm
alana
i can't use my hands you can kind of do
this that's troy bacon
and then that's my pistol and then
that's austin wintery
nailed it look at me flexible
solids i think i'll be all right next
week um yeah i have no idea what i'm
going to title this
as is the issue every time but uh austin
nerds out
star wars again star wars again i think
next week i'm just not going to talk
i think i'll just how dare you sir no
i'm into it keep talking
i want to talk about that medium thing
that you sent us next week
i haven't seen a live action trailer in
a while yeah
excited about that game too that's soon
as well
but i don't know why january is why
they've just announced all this stuff
and then they're like three yeah there's
also the five nights at freddy's
collection is fully
i guess everybody was like the
election's in november the world will be
calm by the time of january
yeah what could go wrong never everyone
will be over that by that [ __ ] in
january
it's very strange i'd be interested to
find out but um i guess we'll we'll talk
about it potentially next week
yay bye